we're starting hi welcome
hello there we go so my name is Dominic
this is Prague we are working for for
many many years together on on this
thing called identity server which is an
you know an extension to to is p.net
core if you like that add certain server
capabilities like you know open ID
connect you know off and so on so our
day-to-day job is dealing with HP nut
core security so we have many customers
well I guess all of our customers these
days are on a spinet core security a the
latest version so a lot of the times you
know they they ask themselves is this
platform does it have all I need
so to speak to implement the thing I
want to implement yeah so the idea
behind behind this talk was basically to
give you an overview like a checklist of
all the important security features that
are inside of a spinet core so that you
can validate yourself you know that is
everything in there that I need to build
an application ok you can imagine it's a
lot of material so we just did a two day
workshop just on some of the aspect of
agent core security so in 60 minutes
really it's it's it's really an overview
don't expect that we can go into any
area in too much detail yeah that's why
I added a couple of references on the
slides for you that you can go
afterwards go learn more okay like more
reading material more samples and so on
so basically that the idea is I uploaded
the slide deck to here so you just you
know take a picture of that I'll write
it down then you can get to the slide
again from the slide that you can get to
all the other further reading links so
to speak okay yeah so we've come a long
way with asp.net security does anyone
remember this year yeah couple of people
how many of these five options actually
work you mean none of them or none yeah
none works you're right what was
passport that's does anyone remember
what passport is is anyone old enough in
the room passport was a product from
Microsoft that got pulled before version
1.0 of asp.net but no one updated the
enum so it's still in there
federated was their second attempt to
put some modern security stuff into a
dotnet it got pulled before they
released it and no one updated inna so
yeah we have a couple of options and
some of them work okay I even spent you
know if if you remember one thing from
this talk never ever write a book yeah
it's it's a waste of time I even spent
like 14 months of my life documenting
all of these things in asp.net I think
four weeks after this book got released
there was a to.net 3.0 so you know
pretty much did anyone read this book in
the room no that's what I thought yeah I
didn't think that one of the three
people were here today yeah so part
actually that I one of the one of the
first projects we work together on you
were proposed a reviewer of the book and
you know anyways that's all gone so yeah
so this is basically our our our
starting point yeah that's the type of
architecture that many people build
these days right we have front ends we
have seconds we have seconds for
backends and you have some security
requirements there you know we have
multiple front end types and
technologies and the users need to be
able to authenticate to our back ends
and you know that might be JavaScript
and native applications and DEP
applications and server to server style
communication and so on that's one thing
we often have you know call patterns
where someone calls the service but
maybe also where the service delegates
the identity
next hop in the system typically you
have something called an identity
provider which abstracts away all of the
authentication needs so that regardless
how this user comes into your system
it's always the same user and you don't
have to implement all of the you know
these variations in in multiple places
typically you have something like in a
policy an authorization policy system
that can can come in many shapes or
forms to basically you know implement
the question like who is the user and
what is he allowed to do and you know
the more building blocks we're adding
this gets more complicated so we need a
solid framework to be able to implement
that ma'am so we're going to look at the
most fundamental security services
provided by a spirit core so we we going
to go on you know from from from bottom
to top not a lot has changed to be
honest in the last year or so in in
security which is a good thing right
because all the years before Microsoft
changed their stuff on a yearly basis
and you know breaking changes for the
last year I think it was stable which i
think is a good thing in security but
you all know that three point always
coming out soon so it's a obtains again
to break stuff and I gotta point out
some some of the things that are coming
in in the next world okay again all of
the simple step rocks Brock's gonna show
they are available on github
using this this URL okay let's get
started so first thing hosting okay so
before we even think about running our
application or hard designing our
application you know you want to host it
somehow
Microsoft has this new web server called
kestrel it's not that new anymore right
it's a couple of years old now but in in
in in depth server years it's pretty
yeah
okay so when they first released that I
read the recommendation boss don't use
kestrel on the internet yeah it's you
know it's very new we don't know yet how
good it really is from from us from a
security point of view so they they said
like the only supported configuration of
care
you know that you have a reverse proxy
in front of it that you know something
that is proven battle tested like nginx
or Apache or is something like this and
then this basically takes the traffic
from the outside world and then forwards
the traffic to kestrel and you know and
the way back starting with version 2
they actually it did a lot of
penetration testing on kestrel got in
many companies and they you know we're
all pretty happy that they finally can
test a new web server because who writes
new web servers these days and starting
with version 2 it's now a completely
supported configurations of the speak to
have careful running on the edge but I
think I wouldn't do it ok I still think
it's a very new web server and attack us
are very creative and I don't you're not
ready yet
no no well maybe they're not ready yet
yeah I don't know even with with that
now being allowed I still prefer this
kind of configuration where you have
something in front that you know has
many many years of being security tested
like nginx for example or Apache or IAS
ok
that being said if you want to do that
be prepared to tweak a lot of you know
parameters because obviously a web
server is a complex thing and they they
try to give you a good compromise
between security and performance so lots
of things to tweak to make it work for
your application you know like you know
timeouts and limits and sizes and and
what whatever it has built-in support
for HTTP now so that's good even even
with the reverse proxy scenario you can
still to HTTPS between the proxy and the
final observer if that is important for
you they have support for both static
HTTP and sni server name indication but
you can dynamically choose the HTTPS
certificate based on the host header
name oh yeah
it's it's getting there I think I still
would prefer the old-school set up I
think good so once you are inside the
host so to speak then basically ace to
the core is basically consists of two
building blocks
we're and services okay the middle way
is the thing that runs on the request
pipeline and the reason you write
middleware is because you want to get
invoked automatically when a request
comes in or a response goes out but the
middle way itself typically doesn't have
a lot of logic it pulls from services
from the DI container okay so all it
turns out all security is services in a
spirit core services in in a dependency
injection container and that's just what
the middle way is using or what your
code would be used or what their
plumbing is using basically so let's
have a look at those the most
fundamental one is data protection so
you have many many situations in in your
web application but you need to protect
data okay the probably the most common
one would be protecting a cookie right
are you showing a cookie you put some
data in there you want to make sure no
one can change that cookie or look
inside or tamper with it and on the way
back you want to validate that cookie so
that that that requires crypto right and
when you hear the word crypto your first
question should be and where is the key
yeah do you remember this the machine
key element in a Jeanette yeah it was
your master key right so you had to
create a master key and and put it into
your config file and you know that
pretty much became the most important
key or string in your application
because whoever had access to that
string could create cookies that look
like they come from you right and
because this was the most important
string in our application we put it into
clear text into a config file on our web
server right yes makes total sense it's
a bit of an outdated design yeah they
had to fix that this key was literally
impossible to rotate to change without
breaking users that are currently using
your application so they basically
changed the whole thing there's now an
official data protection API in a snit
core and the first thing they had to fix
was store that key outside the
application and not inside the
application you know actually could go
one back you wouldn't believe how many
github repos have machine keys checked
in for example yeah or if you want to
have fun try this on Google
which searches for the word machine key
in files that that end with conflict
you'll be surprised ma'am okay I think
in some countries it's illegal to give
this advice yeah I think in the States
absolutely anyways so the first thing
you had to fix was that key material has
to live outside the application yeah
and that that's a good thing but
obviously it creates a little bit more
complexity yeah so they they they have
some default values where they store
their was keys when you are on your
local developer machine they're gonna
use your user profile and inside the
user profile I think we have a screen
shot of that just no one yeah inside
your user profile if you drill down all
these folders you'll find a folder
called data protection keys okay and
that's where they store the master key
for your machine and then even each
application basically is deriving keys
from that master key for their certain
purposes okay one back again now is all
fine for local development scenarios but
once you deploy the application to the
server you have to make up your mind
where do I want to store my keys okay
obviously Microsoft being Microsoft yeah
when you when you deploy to Asha right
there's some magic pixie dust they can
put over your deployment and it just
they take care of it and in the
background but if you have any sort of
load balance or redundant deployment
that you're doing yourself you have to
find a shared location to store these
keys right it could be a file share
could be a database could be radius
could be whatever right it's it's
extensible why am i mentioning that to
you because we have many customers that
were unaware of this because this API is
for most parts invisible right it just
works yeah it does does does it stop
behind the scenes and as every good
security API should be it should be it
not getting in the way okay but now
you're completely unaware that this
thing actually exists you you deploy it
to your server and suddenly you get
weird behavior or intermittently
yes and that might manifest itself as
your users are not able to login right
because you have a lot balanced
environment server one creates a cookie
that cookie goes to server two they
don't have the same key material server
two will say like this cookie is invalid
use I signed out okay so let's have a
look at how we can reproduce this
problem just is just to show you that
it's really a problem yeah so this is a
sample application showing you how you
would configure the data protection
system in your air application and
here's our you know configuration of our
dependency injection system this is
adding data protection by the way never
ever do that what we are doing here
because we are just storing the keys in
the current directory and that's just
for demonstration purposes please yeah
so this is the big one that you want to
know about is deciding where to put the
keys on your system so I have a lot of
customers that do AWS deployment and
they have to configure this in their
application so one of the built-in
functions is to for Microsoft is to put
them somewhere in your file system so
we're just putting them in the current
directory and I don't know if you can
see here but we don't have any key text
files right now in the current directory
okay
and so we have a sample where we're
going to just use the data protection
API directly if I can run this and we're
going to encrypt a string you know
protect a string and then unprotect a
string yeah so so we put it in hello
world right we call protect this is just
our MVC controller using the data
protection API directly so you can use
this yourselves and we're you know
getting our our protected string here
okay so that's very much like what
Microsoft would do with their cookies
internally so over here now in my file
system notice I have a new file key -
some grid XML so this was dynamically
created the first time that a key needed
to be used to do data protection they
put it in the location we told it which
is you know in production not here you
shouldn't be doing here and they have
some information in here about the key
one of them is about the the the
creation date and they had this notion
of an activation date so
the ideas they create these keys and
they're good for or they're being used
for 90 days and the interesting thing is
then after 90 days they actually create
another key so internally they do key
rotation which is kind of a good
practice when you have key material they
still keep the old ones to unprotect old
you know data that was protected with
the old ones but new data will be
protected with the new keys okay so
you'll actually get accumulate several
keys over time and you know this is
actually then being protected with some
local crypto so that if you steal the
file that you know nobody will be able
to then have the keys okay so let's
imagine you do in fact lose your keys so
we'll delete this file okay I'm gonna
shut down my web server where's my web
server oh I'm in the console okay I'm
shutting it down because it had cached
the key in memory all right so I want a
reboot or activist as if it's another
server okay and I'll go back over here
and now try to unprotect okay and it is
unable to unprotect the data because the
key that it was protected with is now
gone okay so some if you're seeing these
exceptions in your log files that's
exactly the problem you're hitting that
for some reason your servers are not
synchronized in terms of the keys yeah
okay and it's the worst day to figure
out this problem is on production on one
on deployment day yeah okay so yeah you
have to plan ahead for that just briefly
this is the interface that you could use
again directly if you wanted to from
your application and you create this
protector and the api's are dirt simple
right protect unprotect you don't have
to worry about crypto or key material
okay cool
[Music]
where is this used cookies is probably
the most common one that you know auntie
for tree tokens it's it's used as well
when you when you're doing often a
standoff money connector there's this
state parameter that needs to be
protected they using it for that as well
if you're doing raiser pages you might
know the temp data attribute that's used
here as well and as proc just showed you
can use it yourself as well and it's a
very useful API when you want to
you know transport data from one page to
another and you want to make sure nobody
can change the data and so on yeah and
then you protect it and send it over
query string or whatever or a forum post
and then on the receiving end you
unprotect it again it can make sure
nobody has tempered your data okay good
so once that base infrastructure is in
place we can now move one level up which
is the authentication system and that's
what we they're the biggest subsystem in
in security terms and you know you
you've seen that enum right
authentication mode equals something
yeah that we've come a long way from
that system to to here okay so first of
all in the old world you could only
choose one authentication level at a
time where you know and that was pretty
impractical so in a steel core we have a
completely revamped of indication system
you can have as many of indication
methods in at the same time in your
application they you know support the
most popular social providers like
Google Facebook Twitter and so on there
are lots of community projects out there
which adds support for their not so big
social born well they're all so big like
you know Dropbox and github and Yahoo is
like pedal net for example untappd you
know the really important of education
systems in the world then we have
support for all of the big standard
space protocols of MIDI connect w's
Federation they both come from Microsoft
if you have to interact with sam'l yeah
like governments and banks use a lot of
sam'l there's an open-source project
from a guy called under sigh I call him
mr. sam'l yeah because whenever I have a
similar question I ask him he knows that
stuff inside out
and if you want to use Sam oh that's
probably the best library to use for
that if you're doing API security you
need support for token-based
authentication so chasing dep tokens is
the most common thing to do here that's
built-in as well and then when it comes
to session management they have an API
you know
or for signing in user signing out user
session management and a default
implementation which puts stuff into
cookies but that is replaceable as we'll
see in a second as well yeah we can skip
that but this year is how you interact
with the authentication system there's
an interface which lives in the DI
container it's called the I of
indication service and there are five
methods on it that deal with the five
different things that you typically do
first of all of course authenticating
something right like validating a cookie
or validating a token you know these
kind of things session management you're
starting a session is called sign-in
stopping a session is called sign out
telling the system that authentication
is required meaning either go to a local
local login page go to a remote login
page you know these kind of things
telling the system that access is denied
which pretty much is a you know your
last resort like I can't go from here
access denied show some page access
denied
I guess contact your administrator or
something like that yeah that's how you
set it up yeah and we all have to have
to go into details here but basically
you wire up these handlers in the DI
container and once they are wired up
there you can use this AI authentication
service to talk to them you never talk
to them directly because there is some
coordination and orchestration necessary
internally that's why you have to go
through that abstraction called the I of
indication service another thing I
should just briefly mention they have
the built-in support for same site
cookies which is a new feature in
browsers which is very useful for making
your cookies more secure read up on that
if you care about these things but the
main point here is you get same site by
default now because all of the cookies
are now set to the same side legs which
is you know not the most secured secure
setting but the most compatible setting
and gives you some good extra security
session management is interesting right
you want to login the user to your
system and sign him out again
that's how you do that basically you
call the sign-in method
on this authentication service it's all
based on claims now right so that's how
you model the identity of the user by
basically creating some claims like name
and a subject ID and first name email
address whatever you want to model
basically and then you pass that claims
principle to the session handler and it
will basically serialize it into a data
structure typically a cookie mia and
they also have support for metadata in
in the session don't confuse that with
their session feature it's the same name
I guess but it's more for like security
related information something you wanna
heart a couple with the login of a user
so maybe you have some access token that
you want to use to call an API on behalf
of that user and that should be
associated with that user so yeah it's
maybe an option at least to to to store
it inside of the authentication session
of the user so it you know they belong
together so to speak okay and I'm gonna
show you a demo in a second that brings
all of these things together like a like
a picker demo or proc will show it there
are many things you can do to me to to
customize the session management as well
so for example there are events that get
invoked like for example whenever a
cookie comes into your system gives you
a chance to run some code and say like
ok this cookie is valid but Institute
are still valid in the database or is it
easy has he been disabled in the mean
time for example do I need to invalidate
that cookie for example it gives you
access to the sign out workflow so if it
sign out time you want to clean up data
for example delete cache entries
whatever that's that that can be done
does that the actual implementation of
the session mechanism is also pluggable
by default Microsoft just stores
everything in the in the cookie that's
probably not the best idea especially
when you start making use of that
feature because cookies have certain
size restrictions right especially when
you use
browsers like Safari you know they they
have very tight limits on on cookie
sizes but the point is you can plug in
other persistence mechanisms like a
database or a care
you know so they take the cookies stay
small and you also get this revocation
feature so you know all you need to do
is to invalidate it a cookie or a
session rather is to delete it from her
from a cache and then the user I signed
out you know nice nice clean feature ok
external authentication means that we
don't do our own authentication but use
some external provider for that like
Google or you know Asha ID or what have
you they have built-in support for that
as well of course them it's called a
remote authentication Handler and they
know basically how to send the user to
this external system and they know how
to process whatever comes back from from
from that external system to validate
who the user is know we'll see in a
second and the last point about API of
and about authentication it's a api's
right so if you want to secure api's
they also have a handler for that it's
called the chasing deaf token handler
and that the top of this angela is to
you know look at incoming requests
validate the tokens and and you know
turn them into claims one thing is
missing if you care about these things
there's a speck called RFC 7 6 to 2
which is token introspection meaning
it's not a chase in depth token it's
some other token type and there's an
endpoint on the network that can
validate it instead of yourself we
provided that handler
it's it on github so if you need that
you can plug that in as a replacement
for this this also works very well so we
have one demo that brings all of these
things together you know it's a lot of
information but as I said it's it's
basically for for giving you an overview
but but this this sample here basically
takes all of the things I just talked
about and turns them into you know one
thing yeah what we have here is an MVC
application and the idea is that this
MVC application is going to log in and
it's going to use an external
authentication system using Open ID
connect once we get the back the
indicated user we will you know
establish a local session with the
cookie and then this application wants
to call the Web API on behalf of that
user so we have another project over
here which is running a Web API so over
here this separate API project is also
of course wanting to authenticate calls
so it does token-based authentication
expecting a JSON web token okay so this
API project let me run that just to get
it up and running okay we now have our
excuse me so over here in this
application we're gonna be wiring open
up open ID Connect there's another
important part of this is when an
application is calling web api's you
have this token and this lifetime
management that you have to deal with
with this token so we have a nice little
sample here that's gonna kind of help
that so let me just run this to get
logged in first and show you first what
we get back and then we'll deal with
calling our API so here's the MVC app
I'll trigger my secure page this just
has a you know an authorized attribute
on the application actually let me show
that as well I think up here we have a
global authorize we'll talk more about
that when we talk about the policy
system but the entire application
requires an authenticated user so what
we've done now is redirected up to some
centralized
identity system somewhere and I'll log
in with a user called Bob that I have up
here right we get a consent screen this
is basically you know hey yeah this is
all the information that we're about to
send back to the application including
access to this API so when we come back
we'll come into this application and
we've now authenticated from the
external system we have claims coming
back from that external system and these
have been issued into our cookie the
other thing that's in the cookie is
Dominic mentioned is metadata and this
metadata is a place where all this other
information is stored one of the things
that is stored in here is are the tokens
coming back from the token server so we
have an access token and this is what
we're gonna send to the Web API this ID
token is that the token that
authenticated us in the first place and
we also have this thing called a refresh
token and that's for you
to go get new access tokens when this
access token expires okay
so right now what we have is a button
here where we can call the API so
actually I think that's already in place
we can call that and this is taking that
access token sending it to our API
endpoint and that was successful okay
so that's great we now allocated the
user external authentication tracking
with a session using the authentication
system in asp net core you know calling
that api the last little interesting
thing here then is this token management
so again I mentioned the token is going
to expire at some point and we use a
refresh token to renew that that code is
a little bit tedious and you don't want
that you know mixing into your
application code so we've come up with
an interesting little technique which
taps into the cookie events Dominic
mentioned that there's an event exists
'm off of the cookie handler and so what
we have here is a class that will
implement these events for the cookies
and there's some virtual methods that
you can implement one of them is
validate principle so this is invoked
every time the cookie comes into the
application after the cookie has been
validated by the by the built-in cookie
handler then you get a chance to take a
look at it and so what we're doing here
is we're not using it to check to see if
the user still active we're actually
leveraging this to get the token our
access token for the API we are checking
the expiration on it right when you get
the tokens back you know how long it
will be valid for and we're checking to
see if we're within some threshold so
the token you get back is good for about
an hour so what we'll do is we'll use it
for 58 or 59 minutes and then oh it's
about to expire so what we'll do then is
we will connect back to the token server
and use the refresh token get a brand
new access token and then we'll update
our cookie metadata with the latest
token so what's nice about this is it's
a sort of a seamless way to
add into your project a way to
automatically refresh the token without
this being in your API code right when
you call the API so I think our tokens
are good for what one minute or
something 70 seconds okay so I've been
sitting here talking for more than 70
seconds so this is the current access
token and this is the Refresh token we
have so I'm gonna hit refresh and what's
gonna happen is the cookies gonna come
back in with these tokens we're gonna
see that the token expiration is past
our threshold so this should just
automatically refresh this so if I hit
refresh ya notice it changed okay
so it's a nice little easy way to put
this in the pipeline if I hit refresh
now yeah it's I'm still not within my
threshold so in 50 more seconds it will
it will do another renewal can you also
show the code how you call the API oh
yes this is really free right so when
you call the API right you need the
token so there's a helper provided to
read the access token out of the
metadata in the cookie we are getting a
HTTP client to connect to the web API we
can use this little helper method to set
the access token as the authorization
header using the bearer scheme and we
just call the API so the point is this
is pretty simple code with calling the
API and not worrying about token
management okay one more thing is that
at sign-outs time as well that's another
event that you can handle on the cookie
events which is hey the user signing out
so the kind of the good proper cleanup
is to go and get your refresh token and
if I go down here far enough we will
revoke it guide the user signed out that
means the Refresh token should no longer
be valid so we're you know cleaning up
the tokens at the token server okay good
all right okay so that's authentication
authorization is another huge topic now
that we could talk for days
I guess about it so authorization
Microsoft rewrote the authorization
system well actually that there was not
much to rewrite to be honest because the
older versions didn't have
yeah but in ethnic or they have a new
authorization system it's actually two
systems even if they are internally the
same but there are two flavors if you
like how to use them one is called
policy based authorization and the idea
is that it's the replacement for the old
authorized attribute right authorize the
directive was its authorized attribute
where people used it took two EE just
like roles equals something right so
it's the two tween for certain role
memberships and since we all know that
roles are not very useful or you know
don't go far enough what many people did
was they wrote their own authorized
attribute right to be honest of you I
I've done a number of code reviews where
people wrote their own authorized
attributes and they did it wrong because
you have to derive from a base class you
have to be aware of what the base class
is doing to call the base first or after
you know and if you get that wrong you
get subtle security holes in your
authorization system so Microsoft
basically remove that feature you can't
write your own authorized attribute
anymore okay what you're doing instead
is you're creating so-called policies
and policies can be invoked from the
authorized attribute and you are and the
policy system is completely extensible
but you can't replace the authorized
attribute anymore okay and the whole
point of the policy system is that you
basically can look at the incoming
request check the properties of the user
and if he fulfills certain requirements
you allow him through otherwise you
access deny ma'am there's another system
called resource based authorization
where in addition you can also have a
look at the resource that this user is
trying to manipulate like updating a
customer or deleting an invoice you know
these kind of things ma'am it's all the
I pasted again so it's actually testable
now which wasn't possible with the old
system and that's a good thing for
security actually if you want to learn
more about that there's a really good
learning resource from the guy that
actually is responsible for the
authorization ap I am at Microsoft his
name is Perry you might know him from
Twitter
he's where
a lot and he wrote like like a like a
hands-on workshop so to speak how to
learn the different you know aspect of
the authorization system in in in the
next version of a steel core this will
be available as middleware as well the
right now it's pretty much unused by MBC
me the authorization API but since since
they want to open more scenarios in the
next version like for micro services and
routing outside of MVC him it's gonna be
a you know like and offer as a middle
way I will be available as well okay do
you want to show just the demo yeah more
exciting than slides okay so this is
another sample we have for showing the
authorization system what I have is I'm
simply logging in a user first of all
right you have to authenticate someone
before you can authorize them just to
show you who our users are I have just a
hard-coded list and let's say we have
Alice and Bob and so Alice is uh in the
sales department and she's a senior
you know executive in the sales
department so that's all well and good
and the idea is in the air' application
you were going to want various
authorizations so the way you set up
using policies is we add the
authorization system into the DI
and this provides add policy methods
this is where you create a named policy
which then has the requirements that a
user must satisfy so think of it as kind
of like a permission right it's the name
of something and I'm expecting this
about the user so the way these policies
work is that they are looking at the cul
in this case the claims on the the user
okay these are very simple so in example
it's a sales only sort of permission you
must be in the sales department you must
be a senior sales person well you need
to be in the sales department and level
senior so these are our both must be
satisfied for the policy to succeed and
then over here on my test controller I
have various attributes that's the same
authorized attribute but now when you
pass in a string you're indicating the
name of the policy okay so you can do
these declaratively using the attribute
also
Dominic mentioned the authorization
services in the DI system so you can
resolve it from the DI system and invoke
this programmatically right so you can
invoke it you know within your method to
you know enforce this this is also a
good way to invoke a policy to update
your UI and like hide and show menus and
buttons if the users not even allowed
don't show them the button for example
okay so I can just run this quick and I
have something else running I think I'm
gonna have to close this oh lucky okay
Alice Alice great so I'm logged in as
Alice and we have our our claims okay so
now when I go and invoke that sales only
because alice is in the sales department
you know that succeeds of course senior
sales right she has those two claims so
that one works that's a different policy
but I have another one which I didn't
show you but it I think it's requiring
that you only be an intern for example
so you're only in the the intern status
and in that particular department so
that one should fail okay and so what's
happening under the covers is that the
authorized attribute here was calling
the challenge or the the for you know
for bid methods right and the forbid is
sending us to the access denied page if
you're doing it imperative lis then it's
up to you to call for bid if that's what
you want or something else custom okay
good yeah yeah so what this kind of
gives you the impression is now that for
being able to use that authorization
system you need it everything has a
claim okay which is wrong yeah just just
because you have this shiny new hem or
not everything becomes a nail now so but
Microsoft provides a couple of pre-built
requirements and they are based on
claims basically but you can extend that
system to when you scroll down here you
see that there's a custom policy yeah
and what this basically is this policy
model is
you're only allowed in if you have a top
level of manager or I don't know
whatever yeah so what is really is this
method here is just an extension method
on this authorization policy builder
that under the covers adds a new
requirement to the collection and when
you when we look at the requirement you
see it's just a class that models your
your domain yeah in that case it models
a top level so to speak and whenever a
policy gets invoked that contains this
requirement at runtime they will look
for a handler that can deal with this
requirement which is in our case the top
level requirement handler okay and then
they invoke the handle requirement
method and then you can write whatever
code you want to to to check if the user
is fulfilling the requirement yeah and
if you're happy you call context or
success succeed on that which means your
requirements exceeded and if all
requirements in the policy agree on
success their policy is a success okay a
very deliberate thing here is these
handlers live in the BI container okay
which means in other words that they can
take other dependencies on other things
that also live in the BI container yeah
so instead of basically modeling every
everything as a claim you see this this
thing is just calling an AI organization
service that might go to a database or
might might call an API can be you know
mocked for testing purposes and so on so
don't be confused that you're not having
to model everything now as claims just
to use the authorization system because
that would be wrong claims are good for
modeling identity data they are not very
good for modeling permissions okay okay
yeah yeah get a part that we don't gonna
show you because it's just not time for
that it's called resource based
authorization as I said instead of just
looking at the incoming subject you can
also add the notion of an operation to
it like read write whatever and and the
resource that this operation will try to
manipulate and this way you know you can
right basically these handlers that take
a third parameter that is the actual
resource that is being manipulated and
then you can basically implement your
authorization logic there and you can
see how to invoke that basically by
calling this method here you pass in the
actual object that is being manipulated
you pass in the operation that you are
about to do and the user and then this
custom code can you know determine if
that's allowed or not it's a framework
from Microsoft that you have to buy into
and you know as every framework you have
to figure out is this what I want or is
it more work to just make the framework
happy then intending and building my own
so you know there's that that's just
something that that we learned from a
couple of projects that some people
didn't like that too much because it was
a lot of ceremony ceremony
yeah but the policy stuff I think is
really brilliant and it's it's by
easy-to-use ma'am okay you wanna talk
about this oh sure
so another important component in the
asp net core security system is a way to
track your users in your database right
so that's what asp.net identity is asp
net identity is a framework or a library
that provides you a lot of the
primitives to do what's necessary to
properly manage user accounts and a lot
of that involves passwords right having
a password when somebody when you store
the password you have to do hashing on
at the right way when somebody comes in
and tries to validate you know on a
login page validate their password you
need to check that you need to worry
about things like brute force attacks
right if you've ever written your own
login page in your own database for your
users you know are you counting how many
failures you're getting for every failed
login so they do a lot of important
things like that in addition right you
have to worry about things like password
reset and how do you do that securely
well you need to email verification and
so there's a whole email verification
component to this and that's hard to do
right so it's a really good starting
point for building out your ID
these system some other features that
they have also is related to
multi-factor authentication and they
support things like SMS and
Authenticator apps and it's extensible
so you could put in your other type of
authentication systems as well lastly
not every user will have a password
right if you're doing an external
authentication against a Google you know
Google logins that user doesn't have a
password but you still need to track
that user in your system so it also has
the notion of having a record for your
user but linking it to the external
provider okay so most of the data stored
in the database is predominantly around
authentication for your user but you
could extend this input other custom
data as well I preference is to put as
little business data into this database
just keep it purely about the
authentication properties you know email
things like that you know for yeah a
telephone number for the multi-factor
things like that
or that you're linked from a Google
account and then the rest of the data
put in your business database at least
that's my preference for style the other
thing that this then provides is so we
talked about cookies for establishing
your session and this library is the
database well there's a little bit of
glue missing in the middle so they have
a little bit additional helpers called
the sign-in manager and that's basically
a component that will allow you to on
your login page receive the password
it'll go do the checks in the database
come back and issue the cookie to
establish the session so it can be very
blurry right where cookies are and where
the database is and this thing in the
middle
but again the code is is up there on
github you can look at it I frequently
have to look at it to remember whose job
is that to issue the cookie and whose
job is it to check the password but you
know it's open source so you can have a
look at it that's yeah well okay all
right good
so the last thing is that's the only
thing that's really new so you probably
haven't seen that yet we have barely
seen it to be honest but I told you at
the beginning that we are working on
this thing called identity server which
adds
missing features 218 core so a Microsoft
implement all of the things that you
need to have for consuming tokens here
like the automatic Kinect angler and the
chase pep-talk and handler but they were
always missing a good a good feature or
a good mechanism to issue these tokens
okay they had several tries they did
tried to solve the problem themselves
and it got they didn't maintain it in
the end because they fought like a it's
it's actually hard to do it the right
way
so on one hand we had this thing called
identity server on the other hand they
had their own identity management
library yeah and kind of they they
approached us or many years ago and
whatever a long story but the short
story is that Microsoft now finally for
the next version ships a little bit of
glue that pulls in our identity server
that pulls in their identity management
library that proc just mentioned and
under the covers makes them work
together without you having to know all
the details okay
they call it zero config yeah and that's
as we all know zero config is not a
reality at least not in reality yeah but
it's a good starting point yeah so
basically the idea that the experience
will be that there will be templates in
Visual Studio you say they file new
tokens secured spa or something like
this yeah and then you will get you will
get the spa data actually working on an
angular and a react version of that you
will get the spa you will get your API
and you will get your identity server in
just one one project they will set up
everything in so that basically you can
press f5 right that's um the f5
experience as they call it yeah the
original plan was to ship that with with
an update to HP nut core 2.2 I to be
honest I'm doubting this will happen
because they are all basically working
on 3.0 right now so but I actually heard
yesterday that in the next preview of
3.0 which will ship by the end of the
that stuff will be in there okay so did
it they're gonna ship now a monthly
preview of a free point oh and that
stuff will be in there that's what I've
got in the next update okay in the
future there are more advanced scenarios
plants like firm for you know micro
service scenarios with where you bring
up an API these API registers
automatically with the token server and
starts using getting tokens calling
other api's and so on to four that's
probably not coming in the first
iteration so to speak how can you have a
look at that today as props that proc
just said it's all open source right so
yeah just clone the aged in oak or repo
okay and check out the tech called
release / 2.2 okay and then and then you
can run that code with with your today
dotnet framework and you don't have to
install any pre-release versions of
whatever and then you basically open the
asp.net identity repo yeah and inside of
that there are the integration libraries
are just mentioned and there's a sample
the API off sample which has all of
these things wired up so let's let's
have a look at their startup so what
what do they mean with zero config
basically you know all the other part is
just boilerplate identity then they pull
in our library they add another line
here which is the zero config they
talked about yeah so that makes all of
the things happen under the covers wires
up the right URLs and cookies and blah
blah blah and then they give you support
for api's that are embedded in the same
application see you don't need to
configure key material and authority
URLs and audiences and so on and so
forth ok yes and then you can just add
api's with you authorize attribute and
and everything's been taken care of so
let's run it I'm pretty sure they're
gonna polish that UI that they have
right now at some point but that's what
you get with the current the current
repo and it's a big solution apparently
so it takes a bit to run it right so
it's completely unstacked Acula okay so
we press the login button you just do
that and it looks like any other ASP
nerdcore template right it's a login
page but if you have a closer look at
the URL here you can see it's actually a
full-blown Open ID Connect request going
on under the covers right but yeah
exactly this part you know it just looks
like any other login page which i think
is the right approach because you know
again security should be mostly
invisible now and then we are logged
into the application we call the API we
get back values they're exciting but
it's all secure okay so that's basically
what we've been doing behind the scenes
of Dave's been doing behind the scenes
for quite a while now and it seems that
in a couple of weeks it'll finally
finally be public okay oh yeah you can
also show them the Chava script no no no
show to show them the server-side
JavaScript that that's not gonna no no
no to go to index CS HTML yeah that's
not gonna be the final way how to wire
up JavaScript lines to tokens they have
attack helper here yeah that's some some
work there but I have from what I have
what they told me is they're actually
providing proper angular and react
components firm for that now and that's
just an intermediate thing okay let's go
back to slides good so that's it that's
done you know that the 60 minute version
of HTML or security there's a lot of
more stuff to learn about it and but I
hope that gave you a good overview or
you know identify the topics that you
want to learn more about yeah have a
look at the samples have a look at the
actually that the documentation for
Microsoft is pretty good these days I
would say now so yeah thanks for that
and if you want stick us we also have
sticker
thank you
[Applause]